>> Tucker: OF THE AMERICAN
STANDARD OF LIVING PLUMMETS FROM
SPIKE IN ENERGY COSTS AS THE
DREAM DIES, THE REACTION OF OUR
LEADERS TO THIS CATASTROPHE HAS
BEEN HIGHLY REVEALING.
A LOT OF THEM SEEM -- WHAT'S THE
WORD -- THRILLED BY THE FACT
THAT AMERICANS ARE SUFFERING AND
THEY ARE EXCITED, THEY ARE NOT
BOTHERING TO HIDE IT AND THEY
ARE EXCITED BECAUSE FINALLY WITH
NO VOTE IN CONGRESS THEY ARE
GOING TO GET THEIR
GREEN NEW DEAL, THEY'RE GOING TO
GET IT BY DEFAULT.
YOU CAN -- YOU ARE GOING TO BE
FORCED TO SWITCH WITH THEIR
CALLING RENEWABLE ENERGY.
THIS IS THE BIGGEST POSSIBLE
CHANGE.
OUT WITH THE OLD UNITED STATES
OF AMERICA, IN WITH THE NEW.
THE LEADERS THINK IT'S PRETTY
EXCITING AS WELL AS OF COURSE
HIGHLY LUCRATIVE FOR THEM AND
THEIR DONORS.
BUT WAIT A SECOND, YOU MAY BE
WONDERING.
CAN WE TRUST THESE PEOPLE TO
DEVELOP AND BUILD AN ENTIRELY
NEW ENERGY GRID TO RUN WESTERN
CIVILIZATION?
DID ACTUALLY KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT
ENERGY, DO THEY UNDERSTAND HOW
OUR CURRENT POWER GRID WORKS?
CAN THEY FIX A GO-CART?
CAN THEY OPERATE A LEAF BLOWER?
TO THESE PEOPLE HAVE ANY SKILLS
AT ALL APART FROM RUNNING
CORPORATE HR DEPARTMENTS AND
GIVING TED TALKS?
THOSE ARE FAIR QUESTIONS.
TO ANSWER THEM YOU MIGHT
CONSIDER WHAT IS HAPPENING IN
EUROPE AS THE NEOLIBERALS SEIZED
CONTROL OF THE ENERGY GRID
THERE.
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL" PIECE
FROM LAST FALL PRETTY MUCH SUMS
IT UP.
"ENERGY PRICES IN EUROPE HIT
RECORDS AFTER WIND STOPPED
BLOWING."
THAT'S THE HEADLINE.
IT TURNS OUT, THAT WINDMILLS
NEED WIND IN ORDER TO PRODUCE
ELECTRICITY.
ON A CALM DAY, THE BLADES
STOPPED TURNING AND THE LIGHTS
GO OUT.
YOU MAY HAVE ALREADY KNOWN THAT,
BUT THE GREEN ENERGY PEOPLE WERE
COMPLETELY SHOCKED TO SEE IT.
IT TOOK A LOT OF PEOPLE BY
SURPRISE, SAID ONE ECONOMIST
QUOTED IN THE PAPER.
IF THIS WERE TO HAPPEN IN WINTER
WHEN YOU'VE GOT SIGNIFICANT
HIGHER DEMAND, THAT PRESENTS A
REAL ISSUE FOR SYSTEMS DEBILITY.
SO CLEARLY WE HAVE A SIGNIFICANT
DESIGN FLAW HERE, BUT THIS IS
2022, SO IT'S HARDLY
INSURMOUNTABLE.
YOU CAN JUST TRUST THE SCIENCE.
OF THE MOST OBVIOUS SOLUTION IS
TO PLACE ENORMOUS DIESEL-POWERED
FANS IN FRONT OF THE WINDMILLS.
THAT WAY WIND FARMS WILL NEVER
BE WITHOUT WIND AND WE WILL
NEVER BE WITHOUT ELLIPTICITY.
IT'S PRETTY CLEVER.
SANDY CORTEZ LIKE THAT IDEA BUT
JOE BIDEN IS THINKING BETTER
THAN THAT.
HE PLANS TO ISSUE AN EXEC AT A
BORDER COMMANDING THE WIND TO
BLOW.
WE ALREADY KNOW THE ELECTED
OFFICIALS ARE IN CHARGE OF THE
WEATHER, THAT'S THE ENTIRE
PREMISE BEHIND THE GREENER DEAL,
VOTE FOR US AND WE WILL CHANGE
THE WEATHER.
SO WHY NOT TAKE IT ONE FURTHER
STEP?
AMERICANS WANT COMMON SENSE
WEATHER CONTROL.
FROM NOW ON HER JOE BIDEN'S
ORDER, IT WILL BE WINDY.
COME O